♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELCOME BACK TO OUR
LIVE SPECIAL, IN THE WAKE OF THE
9/11 ATTACKS, ALL OF US VOWED TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT
HAPPENED, WE WERE GOING TO FIND
AND PUNISH THE PEOPLE
RESPONSIBLE BUT SOMEWHERE ALONG
THE WAY WE LOST THE THREAD.
THAT WAS REPLACED BY CYNICISM
AND SECRECY.
NO ONE HAS EVER EXPLAINED WHY.
FOR YEARS, THE FAMILIES OF 9/11
VICTIMS HAVE PURSUED A LAWSUIT
AGAINST THE SAUDI GOVERNMENT
THEY BELIEVED WERE COMPLICIT IN
THE ATTACKS.
FOR THE WHOLE SPAN OF THE
PERIOD, THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT HAS PREVENTED THE
DECLASSIFICATION OF CRITICAL
DOCUMENTS INCLUDING THE
IDENTIFICATION OF A SAUDI
OFFICIAL BELIEVED TO HAVE
ASSISTED TWO OF THE 9/11
HIJACKERS.
LAST WEEK THE FBI REVEALED HIS
NAME AND THEY DID IT
ACCIDENTALLY.
HE WORKED AT THE SAUDI EMBASSY
FROM 1999 TO 2,000.
IF BRETT EAGLETON IS ONE OF THE
9/11 FAMILY MEMBERS SUING
SAUDI ARABIA, THANKS MUCH FOR
COMING ON THE SHOW TONIGHT.
WHO IS THIS GUY?
GIVES TO HIM THAT GIVE US A
SUPER QUICK EXPLANATION WHY WE
SHOULD CARE ABOUT HIS IDENTITY.
>> I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR COVERING THIS STORY, WHY ARE
YOU THE ONLY PRIME TIME HOST
COVERING THIS?
>> Tucker: BECAUSE I’M
ENRAGED.
>> YOU HAVE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF THE UNITED STATES WEIGHING IN
ON CIVIL LITIGATION INVOKING
STATE SECRETS -- WHO ARE THEY?
WHY ARE THEY WEIGHING IN ON
THIS?
THEY HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT
SOMETHING THEY CAN’T TRUST US
WITH AND WE AREN’T MATURE ENOUGH
TO KNOW IT.
I DIGRESS.
>> Tucker: I’M SORRY, LET ME
STOP YOU THERE, YOU DON’T
DIGRESS, THAT’S AT THE CORE OF
MY INTEREST HERE.
WHAT ARE THEY HIDING?
I DON’T BELIEVE THAT FOR A
SECOND, I DON’T.
IF SOMETHING IS GOING ON HERE,
THEY ARE LYING FOR A REASON AND
WHAT IS THAT REASON?
I DON’T KNOW THE ANSWER, WHAT DO
YOU THINK IT IS?
>> IT’S DISGUSTING.
I LOST MY DAD ON 9/11, THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF OTHER PEOPLE WHO
LOST LOVED ONES AND FAMILY
MEMBERS AND TO FIND OUT -- WE
KNOW THE SAUDIS ARE MURDEROUS
THUGS.
OUR OWN GOVERNMENT IS TAKING
THEIR SIDE IN COURT, THEY ARE
SUBMITTING IN PRIVATE BRIEFINGS
TO THE JUDGE BEHIND OUR BACKS,
NOBODY CAN SEE IT.
THEY HAVE THIS BLUNDER WHERE
THIS GUY’S NAME COMES OUT AND
WHAT IS SO SECRET ABOUT THAT?
HIS NAME CAME OUT AND THE SKY IS
NOT FALLING, PANDORA’S BOX IS
NOT OPEN, WHO IS THIS GUY?
HE WAS LIVING AND WORKING IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., HE WAS
TRAVELING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY,
HE WAS COORDINATING WITH THE
HIJACKERS.
THERE IS A HIERARCHY OF COMMAND.
RIGHT DOWN TO THE HIJACKERS
HANDLERS IN L.A., RIGHT DOWN TO
THE HIJACKERS.
WHY IS THIS A SECRET, WHY IS
THIS CASE SHROUDED IN SECRECY,
WHY ARE YOU THE ONLY ONE TALKING
ABOUT THIS?
THIS SHOULD BE DOMINATING NEWS,
HEADLINE NEWS, IT’S 9/11, AT THE
LARGEST ATTACK ON AMERICA’S SOIL
AND OUR GOVERNMENT IS SIDING
WITH THE SAUDIS.
IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Tucker: NOT JUST THIS
GOVERNMENT BUT THE GOVERNMENT
BEFORE THIS GOVERNMENT AND THE
GOVERNMENT BEFORE THAT.
THERE HAS BEEN A LONG CHAIN,
THEY ARE PROTECTING SOME SECRET
I’M NOT A CONSPIRACY NOT, I’M
THE OPPOSITE OF A CONSPIRACY
NOT, I’M AN OPEN-MINDED PERSON
BUT THERE’S SOMETHING GOING ON
HERE AND I LIKE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BUT I WISH HE
WOULD COME ON THE SHOW AND
EXPLAIN SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY ARE DOING AND WHY.
>> I WISH HE WOULD EXPLAIN IF
YOU’RE GOING TO STAB US IN THE
BACK, AT LEAST LOOK ME IN THE
EYE AND TELL ME WHY YOUR SIDING
WITH THE SAUDIS.
IT STARTED WITH BUSH, IT WAS
PERPETUATED BY OBAMA AND THE
JURY IS STILL OUT.
TRUMP HASN’T HELPED US YET BUT
AM APPEALING TO THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITES STATES TONIGHT, HE
NEEDS TO KNOW WHAT HIS
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS DOING.
HE NEEDS TO KNOW THAT GRENELL
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR ARE
MISLEADING HIM, WHY ARE WE
SIDING WITH THE SAUDIS?
WE HAVE EVIDENCE, HE WAS LIVING
IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
HE WAS FACILITATING AND
COMMUNICATING, MOUNTAINS OF
EVIDENCE WHEN WE DON’T HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE, THINGS LIKE
PENSACOLA HAPPENED.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON AND IT’S
TIME FOR US TO STAND UP, WE ARE
AMERICANS, TIME TO PUT OUR BIG
BOY PANTS ON, OUR GOVERNMENT
SHOULDN’T BE TELLING US WHAT WE
ARE CAPABLE OF UNDERSTANDING,
THEY SHOULDN’T BE PROTECTING ANY
TYPE OF SECRETS.
>> Tucker: I LIKE RIC GRENELL
A LOT I THINK HE’S DONE A LOT OF
GOOD STUFF BUT I DON’T LIKE THIS
AND I DON’T KNOW WHY THEY ARE
DOING IT AND WE HAVE AN ABSOLUTE